infinite warfare has a pretty sprawling
campaign as usual it has progression
heavy loadout based multiplayer and of
course that third prong of the Call of
Duty formula just the batshit crazy
zombies miguel concepción you have
played a fair amount of it now you have
reviewed or reviewing the game for us
and i wanted to ask your thoughts on it
because it looks pretty crazy it's this
80s theme in an amusement park
futuristic sci-fi kind of vibes like
what are your overall impressions well
the first thing the first my first
thought when I played this 80s mode for
the first time is I was very surprised
that there wasn't this kind of mode in
the past this kind of aesthetic usually
that's very low hanging fruit maybe
that's the reason why Activision waited
this long to have a mode like this it's
specifically themed as a serve
Tomorrowland futuristic theme park which
actually fits the rest of the infinite
warfare game despite the fact it's
actually set into 80s yeah it's it's
weird like the zombies like you have you
were saying just before we started this
you were saying they're always kind of
this kitchen sink approach grab bag of
just random like it's not even there's
not usually unifying theme so that's why
this is cool in black ops 3 they had the
noir on you know but they started off
obviously the Nocturne totin at original
underworld at war and that was just that
house which they returned to in black
ops 3 campaign oddly enough but then
there's a zombie factory there's the
swamp there's this like abandoned Arctic
tanker with Johnny Trejo in it like you
were saying it's not usually a unifying
theme
whereas zombies in space land the newest
one infinite warfare really like you
said feel like they're nailing that
aesthetic despite the fact that like
they have so many different things going
on right you have the the neon art style
you have the the hip hop enthusiasts in
the tracksuit you have David Hasselhoff
and Pete and pee-wee Herman aka Paul
Reubens plays this horror film director
who sucks your characters into his space
world themed world implying that the
later maps for infinite warfare zombie
mode will have other settings based on
his fictional is imagined horror movies
I assume if at the back it will Paulo
the other theme parks
so there's some crazy mechanics going on
in this one namely which one you touch
that was David Hasselhoff can you tell
us about that how he figures into this
wind formula you know in this decade of
novelty unlocking him David himself
isn't is a novelty bonus he appears for
what feels like three minutes as a very
helpful NPC within those three crucial
minutes it takes a take some time to
unlock him because you have to complete
a number of challenges challenges that
are based off a random playlist whether
you're killing zombies using melee kills
or having to jump while killing them
which is not easy to do because it's not
like you can do the double jump share in
this mode yeah there's some gravity to
the jumps the regular call to default
jumps you're gonna drop right away right
right
the one thing that yes then the one
thing that impresses me about this mode
is just the level of strategic death
because you have to open up different
parts used to progressively open up the
the theme-park
and it may not be the best strategy to
open up the moment you can afford to
open up certain sections because you do
run the risk of getting separated from
your group but if you do
Duke's do expand the map there are
different sections with a lot of
different types of attractions different
ways to kill enemies in large groups one
of my favorite areas is this arcade that
incidentally has Activision arcades in
them yeah you're telling me that's
awesome and a dance floor that has a
literal laser show that will fry the
zombies and you if you happen to be
there when the lasers activate doesn't
does it not make them dance or am i
thinking is something else no they
actually will dance on the dance floor
plus if you get a an explosive boom box
or ghetto blaster as they were called
back there you can actually get them to
dance on that around that too okay yeah
that was I remember you saying like
isn't Hasselhoff a DJ as well over near
the arcade from when I played yes and he
is sort of he initially appears there as
a tease that you could potentially get
him and he also implies that there's
also a bonus if you manage to get all
three parts of this server robot this
Butler robot
that appears in the game it reminds me a
lot of the I guess the omnibot 2000
there was like this big novelty
Christian air he's robots I think it
appeared in like rocky 3 yeah yeah yeah
oh he brings in Pauly's birthday cake
right remember that's yeah but yeah you
mentioned like the progression and like
opening up the theme park and this kind
of like weirdly methodical like process
to it that's always been the attraction
of zombies because it started off pretty
simple there were three rooms in the
original one in world at war then they
progressively start opening up more and
more and then by the time the one in
black ops 3 rolled around the noir when
it's you know it's there's all these
tricks you learn like a at the beginning
let the zombies tear down the boards
before you shoot him in the head because
then you rebuild the boards get the
money for that leaving crawlers leaving
that trying to blow the legs off and
leave grenades and leaving that one
crawler at the end so he can't catch up
to you but it gives you and your team
time to refill your ammo and rebuild the
boards if you know the powerup but then
that's one of the things my friends I
always played online to figure out these
weird methodical kind of intricate
processes to you know like unlock like
in this case of David Hasselhoff or like
the best gun you know that pack a punch
machine in this scheme there's you have
those cards right how do you know how
those work pretty well you perform well
enough you progress through the mode and
you have the ability they're just like
modifiers you you unlock them and you
can get unlimited ammo your grenade
slots constantly replenish there is like
they're also like one-time bonuses on
the ground and they're sort of like
these loot and dissolute where you could
nuke the entire map so you got a time
one as to when you pick up that that
powerup but going back to what you're
saying about the the crawlers there's a
lot of it's great that you could bring
your tactical knowledge from the prior
zombie modes into this because that
technique with the crawler applies on
this map as well sure
I appreciate that there's all that every
area unlock has this different kind of
terrain where you think you could
actually like funnel enemies down this
one walkway making for easy kills but
you also have to watch behind you and
then you find yourself overwhelmed if
you don't have enough don't have the
right weapons sure it's weird it's kind
of like the craziness of it all belies
the fact there's a lot of nuance to this
mode I mean like it's that three-pronged
approach with Call of Duty games ever
since world at war
you have zombies you have multiplayer or
whatever whatever happens to be whether
Giambi's are a survival or whatever was
in their warfare 3 and then you have you
know the regular campaign but the lead
designer Brian bright when we spoke to
him the lead zombies designer Infinity
Ward recently he was saying the the team
was pretty much given free reign to make
zombies an escape from the seriousness
of the campaign and that like really
intense multiplayer like they wanted
zombies to be go for the kitchen sink
approach go for like the like just all
hands on deck just be crazy with it and
I don't know where do you think it ranks
among the other zombies I don't know how
extensive your like history with zombies
is but does this one like kind of at the
tide of the past years near the top I
think I had the rare opportunity to
actually play a couple rounds with some
folks with from an Infinity Ward at the
event at the review event and we must
have done maybe like three rounds and we
had not gotten past maybe like the 18th
wave yeah and they've told me that their
QA teams at least gone to like 50 yeah
it just goes to show like just how deep
and how deep this mode could potentially
be and how much time you have to put
into it
sure and I'm sure like later on down the
road the DLCs will include new zombies
but from now Tom B's baseline is one
that launches an infinite warfare
correct so that your review is either up
or will be up on site soon at Gamescom
you can read a little bit more about
zombies in your review but until then
stay tuned a game spot for further news
on Call of Duty infinite warfare on the
campaign the multiplayer Miguel's review
will have videos going up all week so
thanks and we'll see you around